dylan what's going on buddy hey guys
i'm doing great how are you doing great
what a crazy time
very very very very crazy now uh you
know i see your uh expert placement of a
book so i'll just ask you well you have
big big debt crisis uh behind you the
ray dalio book uh did you read it
yeah i've read it a couple of times uh
i've been touching it up recently um but
yeah i mean
it's almost just following a playbook to
a t it's pretty wild to see
what are your biggest takeaways from the
book for those that haven't read it or
uh or aren't gonna have time to read it
are there like one or two takeaways that
uh
um
that you'd pull out
yeah it's that ultimately uh in most
credit systems and most currency systems
it gets to a point
mostly just due to kind of uh incentives
of policy makers or or bankers or just
investors in general um to lever up and
the kind of the keynesian response to
that which is to provide more stimulus
ultimately you reach an end point
where you know the the currency system
the monetary system the monetary regime
that you're in
is no longer sustainable um and so you
know policy makers incumbents will do
everything they can to protect the
system
but ultimately it kind of uh in in this
case that the debt cannibalizes upon
itself
uh and and you know a new system and
whether that's a new reserve currency
but from a sovereign or you know say a
monetary commodity a hard asset
rises on the other side of it and kind
of a new a new global standard of value
unit of value is found so
and that's not from my words that's ray
dalio who looked at case study after
case study
and so yeah i think we're living through
historic times
all right you've got a couple of charts
here for us let's start first with uh
the commodities index we were just
talking about wheat oil
nickels in there um a whole bunch of
different stuff uh that uh uh just seems
to be going up into the moon um
what is your read on this like plus 30
is absurd
yeah year to date and so
um you know for for the 2010s we had a
pretty prolonged period of uh
disinflationary commodity trends
kind of riding on the wave of previous
capex cycles
and so you know following the coveted
stimulus and that kind of demand shock
that we gave to marcus we started to see
rising inflation right inflation was at
40 year highs in november when powell
said all right we got to start to get
this in check
and recently um and this is something
that you know no one really could have
foreseen i i guess maybe some
geopolitical experts but uh this this
hot war that's occurring um really the
economic war that's occurring with all
the nation states and russia is just
throwing napalm on this inflation crisis
i got a note here 11 of the global oil
supply 17 of global net gas 11
uh of global wheat and 10 of industrial
minerals are produced in russia um so if
essentially everyone's black mark uh
just saying you know we don't want your
commodities uh and and just kind of
holding them hostage and i think
evidently they'll they'll work with
china but there's no way to just snap
your fingers and make up that demand in
global markets and so
what's the result simple supply and
demand prices are soaring uh and and
there's pretty wide implications for
that
when you look at the bond market
obviously that has a huge impact uh as
well as this all plays out we've seen
incredible volatility to the upside to
start the year uh similar read on this
as well
yeah so i mean if you think about a
fixed income product right uh you're
sitting and you're getting a fixed
payment in fiat currency okay and so uh
if you're if your goal as a capital
allocator is to maintain or grow your
purchasing power you know bonds that pay
uh a coupon that's above inflation is a
good deal you get you get a payment and
not only uh you you grow your purchasing
power nominal terms but in real terms
but if we say have inflation at eight
percent and i think these next readings
with these commodity markets going
parabolic these next readings are going
to accelerate in terms of cpi and so
you're sitting on a fixed income product
what do you do well you dump it you sell
it um so we're seeing massive volatility
in the most liquid markets in the world
like people think of equities as kind of
the driver but really behind the scenes
these fixed income markets these credit
markets uh really kind of set said
everything else and so we're seeing just
massive volatility in in credit markets
we're almost surpassing uh the kind of
coveted crisis and so uh there's trouble
uh and the plumbing is uh is you know
saying there's there's there's something
wrong uh in these in these global
markets and i expect volatility to
actually increase
got it and then when we start to look at
uh the junk and corporate debt that
seems to be in a free fall uh
pretty aggressively you know explain why
that's happening yeah so covered this on
the past couple of your shows uh
previous months and a lot of people
reach out and be like you know aren't
you kind of interested in bitcoin why
the hell are you covering junk debt like
who cares uh and the reality is um you
know behind the scenes there's pretty
big implications uh if these things are
selling off so the principal value of
bonds is inverse to the yield so when
these things are selling off right
because inflation's running hot you own
fixed income you sell it because it's
not a good deal anymore it's not a good
bang for your buck
uh well what happens is the yields rise
and so what what this means and we cover
this a little bit later is not only is
kind of liquidity draining out of these
fixed income markets but also the
financing costs for these corporates is
rising in tandem so so not only are
these fixed income investors delivering
they're they're selling they're getting
these off their books uh but also you
see financing costs really rising across
the board for corporates and so we
haven't even really seen that come into
play yet but this isn't just kind of a
corporate debt or investment you know
junk or investment grade debt corporate
thing this is just basically all fixed
income products because again inflation
is is so rampant and so eventually and i
think what hasn't been priced into
markets yet unfortunately
is that these inflation risks and these
kind of the credit sell-off eventually
leads to liquidity liquidity and
solvency risk uh in fixed income markets
as no one can get can get cheap
financing in a historically
over-embedded economy uh and so you know
there there's uh these markets are
spelling trouble
got it and so when you start to look at
uh things like the corporate credit
spreads uh it seems that uh the drop in
the s p 500 being inversely correlated
uh to uh to these corporate spreads um
you've also overlaid here the vix on top
of it how do you kind of navigate the
the complexity that's involved or the
relationship between these types of
measurements or assets
yeah so you know why look at these at
all what what can they tell you and so i
overlaid corporate credit spreads which
are essentially it's it's the yield on
top of the treasury yield so the
treasury market is that kind of
risk-free global
fixed income market uh it's really still
thought of um as a global safe haven
despite you know a lot of people saying
i would never own bonds it still is that
risk-free rate in the global economic
system so we see this corporate credit
spread meaning uh when this is going up
the corporate credit spread it means
that financing costs for corporates
and this is uh triple b corporates uh is
is rising farther uh than the actual
that treasury yield and so that means
that it's harder to get financing for
these companies and so overlaying that
with the vix you can see there's a
pretty tight relationship um obviously
there's a lot of volatility in the vix
which is a volatility index itself but
there's a pretty you know pretty
correlated relationship between these
two things and i highlighted whenever
both of those metrics or indicators
are rising i highlighted what happens to
the s p 500 what happens to equities so
equity market volatility explodes
and it's more so kind of a function of
this the the lack of liquidity and
credit markets which is reflected in the
credit spreads and what happens the
equity indices dump um and so you know
there's a lot of things happening behind
the scenes here um but recently you know
with i think the nasdaq is 20 off the
highs i'm not sure what the dow or s p
is but uh
really the credit markets we're starting
to say there's a problem back in
november and now with all of this
inflation happening and the kind of
madness in the commodity markets uh you
know the equity equity markets are are
teetering i think that's what's going on
got it and so when you start to look at
things like the 10-year
yield curve uh
how much are these still like a clean
signal
for inflation expectations and and other
metrics versus are these becoming
distorted by uh the complexity of the
market
yeah so uh here we have the ten year in
the two-year yield curve so subtract the
two-year yield from the 10-year yield
and you get what most people refer to or
you know credit traders refer to as the
yield curve and basically this uh this
indicator this metric has predated when
when it inverts when it goes below zero
uh it's called a yield curve inversion
when it's gone below zero it's predated
every single recession since the 1960s
um and and even before that i just
missed one in the 60s it was a false
signal because why
if you think about how the credit system
works most creditors lenders in the
financial system they borrow short so
like banks they'll borrow short and lend
long they'll take on short dated
liabilities uh and acquire elongated
assets
um
you know like they'll borrow from the
fed for you know a year or whatever it
is and land for ten or two inland for
ten um so when this yield curve inverts
when you when you can actually get a
higher yield uh by holding a two year
treasury note than a ten-year treasury
note there's problems because
traditionally that yield curve uh kind
of you'll get a higher yield the farther
you go out in duration so when this
inverts there's pretty big liquidity uh
problems in the market and so recently
it hasn't inverted but we're seeing a
pretty massive uh flattening of this
curve and it looks like uh if we kind of
just focus on the trend
it looks like an inversion is coming
and so and this is the crazy thing is uh
whenever these yield curve inversions
start to happen traditionally we've seen
the fed start to loosen financial
conditions but now we're sitting here
with raging inflation uh and a yield
curve contr a yield curve inversion
potentially coming and the fed funds
rate is still at zero uh so truly
historic and honestly the fed is
completely trapped and what they can do
uh and i you know i would not want to be
jerome powell in this situation that's
what we're talking about earlier is i
don't think that there's a single
off-ramp or out that is positive it's a
lose-lose situation you get recession or
you get inflation uh and in some crazy
way you may successfully navigate both
of those in quick succession uh and end
up causing quite a bit of uh of harm but
again you know if you go back to like
what is the right answer i don't know if
there is a right answer and so uh i know
you and i have a agreement on the idea
of bitcoin being a pretty good solution
you've got the uh the bitcoin price
chart here going back to kind of
beginning of 2020 uh when it was down in
the you know
five six seven eight thousand dollar
range uh what's your read on where
bitcoin is now and how it's reacting to
all this
yeah so just on everything i'm seeing in
credit markets uh
kind of commodities equities big picture
global macro
it looks increasingly likely in my
opinion and i could be wrong here that
we're kind of headed for some sort of
deleveraging or liquidity event okay so
so what does that mean and as a bitcoin
bull how am i positioned well i kind of
you know funny i put an arrow at the
bottom uh kind of at that coven crisis
chart and i said you know bitcoin is
dead it has failed as a store of value
uh and and what i mean is i don't i'm
not calling for bitcoin to go to 20 000
or 15 000 or to get cut in half
overnight like it did in march of 2020.
i don't know
and so you know i am holding some cash
and hoping to buy blood as a long-term
bitcoin investor but i think more so is
i believe when you're talking about the
fed being trapped is ultimately what
we're referring to is there there's if
there is a deleveraging event the fed is
going to be stuck with basically yield
curve control as an option meaning
they're going to monetize any amount of
debt they need to to keep this
game going to keep this credit market
functioning properly and they'll
probably come out and use all sorts of
jargon uh to to explain why they need to
do it but ultimately this is kind of the
end game of this of this system where
you referred to volcker uh right before
i came on i was watching uh well in in
the 1980s uh i think federal debt to gdp
was about 25
right now it's 120
so in terms of in terms of what they can
do and if how high rates can go if this
deleveraging event occurs
uh well because have you sell anything
in a in a liquidity crunch uh and so
what does that mean it means higher
financing costs it means a huge
recession and honestly this sounds
really dark but just on on the debt
loads it means a depression um and so uh
the fed isn't i mean not that they're
not gonna let it happen but there's
gonna be some response and ultimately i
believe the response is mass debt
monetization and
um the mother lode of stimulus which
makes 2020 look like a joke so takeaways
uh the response to all of this madness
uh
a non-sovereign global store of value
that has absolute scarcity and a
production cost
uh is a pretty good bet uh over the
short term expect volatility uh both to
the upside and to the downside and for
that reason i would say if you have any
mark to market leverage meaning you know
exchange rate risk if you have bitcoin
in cold storage you're fine you're in
you're insulated you're going to be okay
go
go you know go take a nap for a year and
come back and tell me what bitcoin's
price is at um
but over the short term yeah i think
there potentially is a is a you know
chance for some some uh some craziness
and some liquidity crunch type
conditions so for dip buyers uh you
might get a pretty nice opportunity but
uh nothing is assured that that's just
kind of what i'm seeing
when you start to think about um
bitcoin's price i think in the short
term we saw bitcoin rise you know at
first
maybe it was up or i think it went down
actually the night of the invasion it
went down you know a couple percent then
it was up as high as 25 from the start
of the invasion now we're probably
sitting somewhere in the you know 10 12
15
range is that what you would expect in
this situation do you think that it was
a less severe move than you would have
expected um is tax selling coming into
april 15 still you know kind of part of
this like just talking about the the
price and what your expectations have
been and kind of how you see uh this
playing out moving forward
yeah so 2022 has been kind of a landmark
year in the sense that we had the
canadian trucker convoy with the
government explicitly just freezing bank
accounts uh seizing seizing money
seizing assets and then followed up by
kind of an order of magnitude or two
larger than this and yes you know it was
a sovereign nation that kind of
committed some some sort of war crime
yeah i i understand that but russia had
its foreign exchange reserves frozen um
so that was kind of for for a lot of
macro economic like economists uh and
kind of you know followers of this
incumbent petrodollar monetary system
they were saying whoa
this is a huge line in the sand
uh sovereign foreign exchange reserves
if they can just be frozen are they
really money um and i think
that kind of has made the case for not
only bitcoin but i mean i think gold is
close to breaking all-time highs today
um for
you know bearer assets in general
something that's not someone else's
liability and so at the same time you
have people that are kind of trading
bitcoin on day to day time frames or
trading correlations they're trading it
based on dollar strength which increases
during kind of financial condition
tightness
but on the other hand you have people
that are saying wait
i think the end game to this is going to
be more money printing and honestly i i
don't think that there's many things
that you can truly own in this
environment
whether you're a political dissident or
you know whatever the case may be
maybe you just want freedom money the
reality is there's not many things that
you can completely control uh and really
there's nothing else that you can
completely control that you can
guarantee no one can can arbitrarily
create more of or dilute uh kind of the
total supply and so in that case the the
bull case for bitcoin has honestly never
been stronger uh there's just kind of
some short to medium term headwinds i
believe um that could that could lead to
somewhat of a of a good buying
opportunity if we get that uh and on
what time frame i'm not entirely sure
but this is just kind of what what i'm
seeing so long term bullish i still have
uh more bitcoin than i ever have and i'm
feeling really good about it
joe john what questions you guys got
dylan what's going on with gold man it's
uh it's at an all-time high or close to
it at least what are your thoughts on on
uh gold bugs celebrating what they
should be looking forward to and so on
yeah i mean congrats uh you know
the golden bitcoin community is bigger
back and forth uh but i think
you know really they they're on the same
kind of mission of
sound money uh and something that
governments can manipulate uh i guess
maybe you could argue that gold the
paper gold price could be manipulated
but uh something that's outside the
hands of you know 12 12 men in a board
room uh deciding you know whether to
arbitrarily increase the price of money
or decrease it and so you know congrats
uh i think you know we the golden
bitcoin community has more aligned than
many of the gold investors think and
maybe even bitcoin as well but uh i have
my bets placed on on uh where the future
is going this is the only gold i own uh
but
i'm happy with it
john
dylan when you look at what's happening
in russia and stuff is everyone they
can't really seem like they can go to
stocks they don't know if a recession is
coming or not is this a big event for
bitcoin in the sense of like this is the
perfect storm people should be running
to this asset um and not kind of putting
their money elsewhere when they need
liquidity
yeah i mean i honestly i'm a i'm in
favor of right now just continuing to
auto stack bitcoin but also stacking a
little uh you know stash of cash i don't
think that's a bad idea cash over the
long term i believe is trash uh you know
ray dalio has been saying that but uh
when you have this uh kind of debt
system or this this monetary system as
engorged in debt as it is you're gonna
see these rapid unwinds and these rapid
delivery things that happen right march
of 2020 everyone thinks it was just the
code lockdowns um the reality was that
the system was was so over leveraged
that some sort of volatility explosion
liquidity event likely would have came
it would probably it definitely wouldn't
have been as bad but it would have come
it's the same thing that happened in in
08 it wasn't a function of
this thing or that thing it was just
kind of a mathematical uh event that
happened because there was credit
impairment and everything counterparty
risk and balance sheets unwound um so i
think that's what we're experiencing uh
obviously the commodity and you know uh
event and the russia ukraine war has a
pretty major role in this uh in the
inflationary spike but yeah uh i mean in
terms of uh kind of a boon for bitcoin
uh over the long term yeah it's the the
rubicon has been crossed in my opinion
uh in terms of the legit the
legitimization of this asset and so
short-term headwinds long-term never
been more bullish and i think a lot of
people are waking up to it gotcha
dylan when you start to think about uh
bitcoin's price what do you think um
what do you think drives kind of change
here is it just literally more people
being educated more time in the market
uh and it does its thing do you think
that there's some sort of inflection
point that occurs uh whether it is you
know a nation state buying it or
whatever like how do you kind of look at
into the future various events around
bitcoin
yeah so i mean i've had a lot of people
uh in my replies and dms being like hey
you know you're not posting as much on
chain stuff
and the reality is the on-chain supply
dynamics look fantastic
i think more so just in terms of if
you're looking at the market right now
and what's driving everything it's this
macro backdrop that we're describing but
off the top of my head and don't quote
me on this but i believe uh in terms of
bitcoin held over the last three months
86 percent of supply hasn't moved i
think that's that's an all-time high or
close to an all-time high over the last
six months i believe it's around 75
almost an all-time high and for a year
61 hasn't moved i think that's also if
not an all-time high very close to it um
so you have a really kind of squeezy
supply side uh in terms of the free
float isn't all that much
uh and i know my personal kind of thesis
here uh is that you know if we see and
you know i believe when we see some sort
of liquidity event deleveraging uh
bitcoin's exchange rate will take a hit
maybe there's some derivative market
liquidations price goes down the the
skeptics come out and say you know it's
dead it's not a store of value it didn't
it couldn't stand a recession it
couldn't stand a liquidity crunch uh
whether or not the fed response time is
fast or not i think bitcoin
forms a bottom and ultimately uh i
believe the monetary easing will come
back but regardless that stackers of
last resort and just how kind of
tight that free float supply is of an
absolutely scarce asset
i think on the other side of this
bitcoin rips unlike any other asset
similar to kind of maybe not a direct
repeat of 2020 but kind of a pretty
similar uh you know central bank or a
fiat system unwind with really solid
supply dynamics in bitcoin leading to
kind of a parabolic run that's kind of
my base case uh and so you know i'm
happy to stack at a discount
and i think you know that's on the other
side of this is when bitcoin truly kind
of everyone comes to realize it's the
thing that you need to own uh during
kind of this mass debasement of fiat
currency
it's it's uh
[Music]
it's pretty crazy to watch this um
let's go to the extreme
is the dollar
failing as the global reserve currency
is there another currency that replaces
it other than a non-sovereign
uh you know currency like how do you
think about
uh just
more of the like geopolitical and like
nation-state currencies reserve status
et cetera as this all unfolds
yeah so i mean if you you know some
people have been saying and i think
dalia's thesis is you know the ccp and
the rnb and and all that
and i personally i disagree with that
because
in order for a world reserve currency
you have to keep your capital account
open you have to allow for free uh free
trade uh and you know capital inflows
and outflows outside of your borders uh
and so i don't see that occurring in
terms of you know the euros cooked uh
there's really no other kind of
legitimate uh option uh other than the
dollar like we we rag on the dollar a
lot but the reality is the dollar is the
best of the worst uh in terms of in
terms of stability and kind of uh
holding it's holding its value up
there's so much dollar denominated debt
out there that during kind of these
financial crises the reason that
everything sells off and the dollar
actually spikes you can think of it as a
dollar kind of bidding is because of
that dollar denominated debt and when
debt defaults occur that dollars are
being like actively destroyed and so
that's why kind of the dollar still is
king uh even though even though we think
the end game and i truly believe that
then game is that you know it's melting
in value we have kind of super spikes in
this in this dollar value but in terms
of legitimate replacements uh nothing
else even really comes close which is
why a lot of people are talking about
kind of a commodity-backed currency in
the east in terms of like russia and
china and a basket of commodities some
are saying gold some are saying you know
trade weighted basket i personally
believe the end game is bitcoin uh and i
you know i don't expect putin to come
out and say you know i'm a bitcoin bowl
tomorrow or even say it at all
but i think the game theory points to
bitcoin uh in this kind of trustless
environment um being embraced eventually
by individuals institutions and
sovereigns everywhere but uh we're still
pretty early in that game i imagine yeah
it's uh it's pretty incredible
um all right we got to let you go
but before we do that how are we looking
on uh on followers it's like your super
bowl man you've been all over this i
feel like
[Laughter]
133.3 that's a lot of threes in there
maybe we next the next three stop is
three hundred thousand because everyone
who's watching this right now it's gonna
follow you on twitter obviously that's i
think i've been shadow band to be honest
i some people were replying to me and
they and then people replied to them and
they couldn't see the tweet above it so
i don't know maybe uh maybe that's
that's hurting me maybe not but
well that's the twitter platform that
you can send them to your newsletter the
deep dive
let's go yeah subscribe to the deep dive
we cover all this stuff in depth every
day uh and we're putting out monthly
reports that are 30 30 pages long with a
bunch of charts and so
uh if you find that valuable and you
like some of this stuff that we cover uh
make sure to check it out
awesome man thank you so much for coming
on you always got uh tons of great
information uh and uh the world is
changing quickly so uh
as uh
as i always say keep your eyes peeled
your head on a swivel you never know
what's gonna happen right
indeed
see you later